hola bienvenidos a este programa
especial la serie en flash 24 yo soy
andrés meza muñoz este 20 de enero yo
bailé en toma posesión como el
presidente número 46 de los eeuu vaya y
tendrá por delante un sinnúmero de retos
uno de ellos lidiar con un virus que ha
dejado más de 23 millones de
estadounidenses contagiados y ha cobrado
la vida de casi 400.000 de ellos eeuu es
uno de los países más afectados en el
mundo por la pandemia pero dentro del
país los latinos y los afroamericanos
han sufrido los efectos más duros del
cob y por la falta de cobertura a los
servicios de salud y por la
discriminación que se ha incrementado en
los últimos años nuestro corresponsal en
washington cristóbal vázquez encontró
una latina que perdió a su hermana por
un contagio de kobe 19 que le fue
diagnosticado demasiado tarde
juana vega es una salvadoreña que lleva
33 años viviendo en eeuu su única
hermana y mejor amiga calixta leonor
tovar falleció al inicio de la pandemia
juana responsabiliza en gran medida a la
muerte de su hermana a la negligencia de
los médicos ya las carencias del sistema
de salud para los más pobres ella va a
la clínica de cardoso a que a hacerse el
chequeo
entonces que hicieran la prueba del cob
y no le quisieron atender
le dijo el que le atendió de que ella lo
que padecía era de la diabetes que los
dolores que tenía de cuerpo y de cabeza
era diabetes señora váyase para la casa
que yo esté aquí lo puede agarrar le
dijo váyase calista leonor era ciudadana
de eeuu murió a los 55 años dejando una
familia con tres hijos por ser hispano o
tal vez la menor ya no tenemos un seguro
bueno y las medicinas a lo mejor quizás
no son las propias para eso porque si
algo otras personas con niveles más con
mejor economía mejor posiciones se
salvan la clínica del pueblo a la que
calista y juana visitaban con frecuencia
para sus revisiones médicas ayuda a las
minorías con falta de cobertura en
washington a responder a sus necesidades
de salud sobre todo de cara a la
pandemia la agresividad la hostilidad el
atropello realmente verdad que nosotros
hemos visto de la administración a
nuestra comunidad se ha manifestado en
miedo a recibir servicios
muchos problemas de salud mental en la
práctica el él
problemas sociales que también
perjudican a la salud más de 57.000 a
latinos han muerto de covite en eeuu
según el centro de control y prevención
de enfermedades los latinos son tres
veces más propensos a contagiarse del
virus que la población blanca siendo así
la minoría que más ha sido afectada
junto a los afroamericanos baiden
contempla una serie de propuestas para
hacer frente a la pandemia de kobe 19
entre ellas garantizar que todos los
estadounidenses tengan acceso a pruebas
regulares confiables y gratuitas
planificar la distribución efectiva y
equitativa de tratamientos y vacunas
implementar mandato de uso de mascarilla
en todo el país
pero estas propuestas están llenas de
desafíos esto lo discutimos con sandra
pedraza una médica colombiana que lleva
más de 20 años ejerciendo su profesión
en eeuu y es directora de medicina
paliativa del símbolo inmemorial house
espiral de johns hopkins el primer gran
reto será invertir en la infraestructura
médica y que un mayor número de personas
puedan tener acceso a una cobertura en
el servicio a la salud necesita tener
una infraestructura que asegure que los
pacientes puedan acceder a los
diferentes hospitales y puedan ser
atendidos a tiempo que puedan tener
acceso rápido a sus necesidades médicas
y que los servicios de salud que están
ya actualmente puedan ofrecer este
servicio a la población en general
entonces se necesita mucha organización
y mucha infraestructura otro gran reto
tiene que ver con el plan de vacunación
la coordinación y la
homogenización de cómo se iba a
implementar el sistema de vacunación
fue claro entonces y al no ser claro lo
mismo que por ejemplo pasó con las
recomendaciones de bioseguridad que cada
del estado
asumió autoridad en cómo se debía
implementar el sistema de seguridad y al
mismo tiempo cómo se hace la
distribución de vacunas crea un poquito
de confusión
que lo que se debe hacer y por qué se
debe hacer hasta que la serie de frases
24 en nuestras próximas emisiones
estaremos abordando otros retos que le
esperan a bailén en temas como la
diplomacia y el cambio climático
quédense con nosotros